[Music]
have you ever thought about whether it's
possible to crack your password simply
by trying different combinations how
long would that take let's start with
the theory suppose for Simplicity that a
password is tried at a rate of 1 per
second then 1 second equals one password
attempt and the following amount of time
would be required for a Brute Force
attack for 100K passwords it is needed
28 hours for 1 million passwords 11.5
days 10 million passwords 3.8 months 100
million passwords 3.2 years and for 1G
passwords it's going to take 31 years
everything is clear with time so does it
turn out that everything depends on the
number of combinations of our password
and how many can there
be firstly it depends on the type of car
characters used there can be four types
a letter a digit an uppercase letter and
a special symbol secondly on the number
of characters or the length of the
password let's look at the simplest
cases for writing commands we will use
masks which are commonly used to record
passwords in the most popular Brute
Force programs these are John and
hashcat The Masks are formed as follows
if you are interested in how they are
decrypted pause this screen and read
unfortunately Brute Force foring on
Modern computers is quite fast
significantly faster than one password
per second for example cracking a psk
hash of Wi-Fi on an average graphics
card which is often used for this
purpose can work at a speed of several
million per second therefore to estimate
the complexity it's sufficient to just
drop Six zeros so for example 218
trillion becomes 218 million seconds
let's see what the resilience would be
for this password it's eight characters
long and uses all four character
groups this equals 6.6 quadrillion
combinations even if the password is
cracked at a rate of 6 million a second
this still amounts to 1.1 billion
seconds or 34
years but what if a powerful Corporation
with colossal Computing resources is
against you in this video we will
discuss whether in our time someone can
really Brute Force any password and if
there's someone is not just a hacker but
for example a
government this video was created by
suub the verification platform we make
the digital world people friendly yet
secure brute force in hacking refers to
the method of attempting various
combinations through a forceful approach
in brute forcing passwords or access
keys are typically the targets there are
online and offline Brute Force attacks
the key difference between offline and
online is who performs the password
check online it's the server offline
it's the hacker we will not discuss
online brute forcing here in our times
it's practically unfeasible as you will
simply be blocked after a few incorrect
password attempts plus the password
cracking speed online is generally low
we will focus on offline brute forcing
which is only limited by the speed of
the processor or graphics card imagine
you are someone with valuable assets to
protect and you store crucial data on
your computer for instance access keys
to assets worth hundreds of millions of
dollars or a database containing
personal details of Q andon Theory
supporters you have an encrypted hard
drive like bit Locker veracrypt looks
and on it a password manager with an
encrypted database like keep pass how
could someone access your data the first
thing they would likely do is steal your
laptop with sufficient resources this is
not too difficult theft combined with
hacking and your laptop ends up in the
wrong hands or in the case of a
government they might just officially
seize it during a search next they would
remove the laptop's cover extract the
hard drive and connect to it
directly they'll see the partition table
but won't be able to connect to the
partitions and view the
files as you can see the system displays
this
to access the file system the encryption
key is needed which in turn is encrypted
with a password to crack it we
essentially need the hash sum of the
password what is a
hash well passwords are no longer
transmitted over the network or stored
on hard drives or databases in plain
text that's true isn't it hopefully you
don't have a file named password on your
computer do
you in General passwords are stored as
hashes let's take a password query then
using a software algorithm called a hash
function we read this password and
calculate it hash sum from query we get
this sum this is an md5 hash sum this
sum is the value corresponding to our
query password and it's called hash it's
this hash that can be stored in your
hard drive or in the database when you
enter a password the hash function is
activated again calculating the sum of
the password you entered then this sum
is compared with a control # sum and if
they match Bingo you are
authenticated but there's one important
feature of the hash
irreversibility that is the hash sums
value cannot be converted back into a
password it's just such
mathematics the only way to recover a
password from a hash sum is by brute
forcing input values calculating the
hash sum for each and comparing them
this is exactly how offline Brute Force
Works particularly vulnerable to hacking
are weak passwords like our example with
querty by the way this type of password
is called keyw walk it refers to a
pattern programmed using a keyboard the
main feature of keyw walk is visual
memorization using such passwords we
don't remember them but remember how to
type them on the keyboard in a snake
Circle crisscross pattern and so on here
are the main types of weak passwords
dictionary password a common word Too
Short within a range that can be fully
brute forced consistent keyboard
combination keyw walk personal data
Distortion of specific words relevant to
the situation like the name of a project
or a website's name thanks to
specialized hacking programs it's not
necessary for the hacker to match a weak
password exactly letter by letter with
the victim's password it's enough to
understand or assume the core of the
password and then add a second or third
phase of matching
here's what it can look like the first
phase is the basics usually simple words
for example access the second phase
combinations of these very words for
example all combinations of two words or
all combinations of three words
combinations using a specific symbol are
also
possible the number of all possible
words is finite and no matter how
Whimsical a combination of words you
come up with the computer will generate
that sequence to
finally the third perhaps most important
phase modification or
Distortion one can try to distort the
word according to established rules for
example replacing the letter s with a
dollar sign or an o with
zero these operations in specialized
programs are performed by what are
called
rules they also know how to add prefixes
suffixes try to swap uppercase letters
for lowercase and vice versa or replace
letters with others that are similar in
appearance ultimately the conceptual
generation of weak passwords looks
something like this here is an example
of how exactly a hacker would think
while trying to crack a
password the implementation of brute
forcing all possible words is not that
complex all it takes is a list of all
words we are now on a website that
contains such a database and its size
there are 333,000 words with various
Endings by the way such a text file
weighs only 2.7
mbes next we might need their
combinations since each word can be used
as a phrase or using a
delimiter to generate such passwords you
can use a program if you're interested
pause and take a look we have commented
on each
[Music]
command generating combinations of all
special symbols with each word
then we get combinations of all words
through all special
symbols similarly for password phrases
consisting of three
words now just combinations of three
sets of words where two of them end on a
special
symbol
the final step would be the Distortion
of the generated password phrases people
often enhance the strength of their
passwords with capital letters special
symbols or numbers at the end for this
purpose so-called rules are used in
password cracking pause here if this is
important to you and read our comments
on the
[Music]
commments a common practice is also
replacing letters with similar looking
number numbers and symbols this is also
accounted for with rules depending on
the set of letters each character is
replaced with a similar looking
one ultimately with this approach we can
generate almost any insecure password
and in reality we can find almost
anything in the list of
candidates with the First Command we
made combinations of all words through a
special symbol and with the second one
we applied the above mentioned rules
adding a special symbol at the beginning
and end of each phrase and Performing
leak
Transformations so let's return to our
situation someone has stolen your laptop
and gained unrestricted access to your
hard disk what will they do dictionary
password first they'll check the
password against dictionaries this is
the simplest path requiring practically
nothing from the hacker large
dictionaries already contain password
phrases of all groups as they are often
formed from real sight leagues and
contain real passwords for example the
most popular dictionary rocku or another
example a huge 30 GB dictionary week P
two also for every password the hacker
tries the top 64 most popular password
distortions the hash cap program comes
with its built-in set of the most
popular types of distortions distortions
will make those same familiar
Transformations substitutions of numbers
special characters lead speak
Replacements Etc there will be exactly
64 for each candidate
password the password is not cracked and
the hacker realizes that the user is not
so naive and they will need to think
harder next the hacker will use a
utility and for security reasons we
won't show you its site this program can
generate passwords based on keyw walks
the kwp program takes a set of keyboard
symbols initial values as well as the
number of keys and turns and generates
all possible combinations of close
symbols obtained by pressing on the
keyboard let's say now the password is
corrected next the hacker penetrates the
file system and quickly finds a specific
file by extension the key pass password
database this is a specialized free
open-source password manager using a
special script from the set of the
similar program John the hacker passes
the key pass password database and
extracts the necessary material for
Brute
forcing the hacker runs the hash through
dictionaries and the keyw walk generator
but in vain then they proceed to the
following targeted password ATT text
knowing enough about the victim the
hacker tries to create targeted
dictionaries generating a password based
on the company name applying previously
described
distortions generating a password based
on all possible company employees
surnames appended with two letters or
initials at the end and applying lead
speak to
distortions Bingo the password is
correct one of the most effective ways
to prevent a Brute Force attack is two
Factor authentification also known as
2fa this adds a second layer of security
to your authentification systems by
requiring users to provide two forms of
identification before accessing their
accounts hi again this is Lucas from
ssub here at suub we can catch fraud
instantly providing businesses and users
with a one-time password backed up by
biometric authentification such as
liveness with liveness in place only you
can access your account no matter how
hard the frauds a strike your users get
authenticated instantly on their
smartphone or webcam in one quick motion
to learn more about this unique
technology click on the link below
how can you avoid being a victim of
brute forcing your password should not
contain words or combinations of words
it should not have keyboard combinations
like keyw walk and it should be of
sufficient length combining all three
recommendations is important even if
your password is mega long but consists
of words it can be cracked as the number
of words is finite and their
combinations are also finite even if you
put a special symbol at the beginning or
end it only adds a bit of resilience and
as we showed in the examples above with
enough effort it will still likely be
cracked if your password includes keyw
keyboard combinations it's also
vulnerable as the number of such
combinations is
finite finally the length and types of
characters it's important to use all
four groups of characters and have a
length of at least eight in other words
a resilient password is a completely
random set of characters from all groups
of s efficient length the best solution
here is automatic password generation as
your brain will involuntarily want to
use a convenient easy to remember symbol
to assess the resilience of such a
password you only need a bit of math if
we return to the situation where the
hacker was trying to hack our 8
character Wi-Fi password and instead of
four gpus the attack has had 1,000 video
cards then cracking this password
instead of 34 years would take a couple
of months add more power
for example 10,000 gpus and then
cracking the password will take only 6
days but what if our password was not 8
characters but 10 let's try adding a
couple of characters to the
password now it's 10 characters from
four groups and already six quintilian
combinations which will now take
1,283 years on 1,000 gpus or 128 years
on 10,000 gpus making an attack on your
password absolutely pointless of course
there's a chance that your password will
be cracked in the first year about 1% if
this worries you then just add another
character to your password and now it
will have to be cracked for almost
12,000 years on 1,000 video cards feel
the power of each character on your
password and if your password consists
of 20
characters in general don't skimp on the
length of your password remember each
additional character of your password
makes it 95 times stronger and
correspondingly almost 100 times more
expensive to crack and answering the
question asked at the beginning of the
episode no even a government is not
omnipotent if we are of course talking
about influencing technology not a
person because simple math cannot be
bribed even with big money and cannot be
scared even with the most terrible
weapon